biden moments ago calling on new york
governor andrew cuomo and saying he
should resign
this comes after state investigators say
he broke the law by sexually harassing
11 women and retaliated against a former
employee
back in march you said that if the
investigation confirmed the allegations
against governor cuomo
then he should resign so will you now
call on him to resign given the
investigators said the 11 women
were credible i stand by the statement
are you now calling on him to resign yes
and if he doesn't resign do you believe
he should be impeached and removed from
office
let's take one thing at a time here i
think he should resign
cuomo defiant as ever claiming the
investigation is political and says he
did nothing wrong
i want you to know directly from me
that i never touched anyone
inappropriately
or made inappropriate sexual advances
they ascribe motives i never had
and simply put they heard things
that i just didn't say and cuomo trying
to defend himself by claiming he kisses
everyone and showing this very bizarre
and horrible picture montage
i love the montage me too
there we are the montage was horrible
but a couple of people we have it now
we've got to play it for you let's watch
indeed there are hundreds if not
thousands of photos of me
using the exact same gesture
i do it with everyone black and white
young and old
straight and lgbtq
powerful people
friends strangers
people who i meet on the street well the
one we didn't show you was the ones
where he used president obama and
president bush hugging hurricane victims
as if that was the same thing jesse it
looks like you brought some thoughts
i have the report here needed a forklift
to get into the studio
did i read the whole thing i read the
executive summary
it's pretty damning i thought we had the
worst mayor now we have the worst
governor
so these are the allegations kissing on
the lips grabbing butts and breasts
asked the state trooper if she could
help him find a girlfriend who could
quote
handle pain love it groping waists legs
and backs sliding hands pretty much
everywhere and just relentlessly hitting
on every aide that was alone with him in
an elevator or his office
my ad now this report was written by an
ag who has aspirations politically and
it said these all these women were
uncomfortable scared humiliated and
offended
and the ag found his responses contrived
and lacking credibility and then he just
denied everything
and said that it was misinterpreted or
even accused some of the women
of initiating the physical context some
of the stuff was interesting it could be
like
obvious misinterpretation so he brings
some woman into his office and he shows
the woman
a humidor that president clinton had
given as a gift
clinton and he explains the humidor and
she
perceives that as some sort of subtle
romantic
suggestion involving monica lewinsky we
get it
now he counters that he shows people to
come into his office gifts from all
types of people
and one of the things he says that
inside the humidor here we have
legal cuban cigars we got these cigars
before the embargo
was put up so that's open to
interpretation the video was incredible
because i actually thought it was
convincing
until he shows videos and pictures of
obama hugging hurricane victims
and george h.w bush hugging katrina
victims the
the line is you can hug or kiss
on the cheek he was grabbing you know
what and kissing on the mouth
that is unacceptable so he says new
yorkers aren't naive and they're not
going to go for this and they know it's
political and you know what
maybe it's an italian thing yeah right
and that's what italians do and that's
what old guys do and
i'm just looking at me i'm sorry and i'm
gonna hire a consultant to tell me
maybe i shouldn't do this anymore case
closed can you hold on
well i don't know i don't know the news
that was just made right before the show
was that joe biden
stood by what he had said back in i
think march or april in which he said
that if he's uh found to be guilty
he should be um uh resign and that he
might even be prosecuted
so president biden though katie just now
in his press conference he doesn't
answer the question by saying
andrew cuomo should resign he just says
yes
yes so that you don't actually have the
words but the meaning is there
he's calling on the governor to resign
does cuomo survive
this part well back in march joe biden
walked himself into a corner by
answering a hypothetical because the
question was
if these things turn out to be true will
you ask him to resign
should he resign he said yes so today he
had the option of going back on his word
or saying that he should resign by
simply answering the question yes
if i were advising a governor cuomo
being paid to advise him or if i were
his brother
who's a anchor at another network i
would advise him not to resign
i would say the democratic party has
made mistakes on this before
al franken is one of them bill clinton
went on after the 90s to be
a star at the democratic party made a
lot of of
you know people famous had a lot of
endorsements made a lot of money through
the clinton foundation
and when it comes to the state
legislature because this
the report is not a criminal indictment
and the attorney general of new york
said that today that she can't pursue
criminal charges
that other charges can be pursued it's
up to the legislature to do this and
that comes down to
cuomo democrats uh being loyal to him
and the left in new york who is thirsty
to get cuomo out uh because they're on
the side of the attorney general and
that's where it does get very political
so in terms of whether he will hold on
or not
is to be foreseen but based on other
scandals that democrats have been
through
and survived i would say he can survive
yeah what's your take on that well the
guys weathered more storms than the
gordon fisherman
feel free to use that america but i mean
at this point he has more accusers than
supporters
but he also we were like watching two
stories at the same time
the actual story itself and will the
media have the attention spanned
and not get exhausted by the story
before before we do before we should
so he is counting on that because he
understands how the cycle works
we report report report and then we
watch our ratings dip and we move on to
something else and he's just saying
i'm going to ride this thing out unless
he borrows some black face from governor
northam
he might end up sticking around i love
the montage
uh the logic makes no sense imagine if
if dana showed people pictures of jasper
and jasper's on your lap and you're
kissing jasper and then you're in hr to
go but i do it with my dog
i do it with my dog you know but uh
that would be quite a story also i
didn't know about the pain thing about
what he said to the cop well that's a
little kinky
that that goes totally to the uh the
nipple clips and things that we've heard
about what i'm saying but i uh the other
thing that he kind of um
points out which is interesting in the
montage and he's kissing all these men
and grabbing their faces and he's kind
of reminding that maybe genders
maybe sex this biology is different
you know it's like you know right there
you go yay but you can't do that to a
girl
and you can't do that to a girl in your
office that's not what they were saying
i mean
i mean from a legal standpoint what do
you think his position
is well i'm glad you asked me a legal
question first of all i
agree with katie's analysis absolutely i
think she had it nailed
al franken as the ghost that should
haunt people who are
you know pulling the trigger already do
you think this is different than they
all frankenstein i do
well it may be different but there will
be regret
uh pick up that thing again jesse this
this
ladies and gentlemen for all its
impressive heft
is not a legal document that is a
political document
a document put together by the furthest
left
politician in elective office in this
far
left state leticia james i've known him
forever
she is absolutely furiously
longing for andrew cuomo's job
i'm not saying that the the allegations
are false so i make no judgment about
that
i just want people to know this is not
proof
this is politics now comes a legal
process he has due process rights
just like anybody else and i would urge
him as katie did
to tough it out make your case prove
that you yeah well you'd have to prove
your innocence but prove that these
allegations against you are false
you know your father weathered his own
storms different type storms
wonderful man mario cuomo uh you know
there's a very public family
matilda the mother still alive wonderful
lady
i think that uh i give him at least 50
50 maybe you want to clarify what five
one thank you
i am i am not urging andrew cuomo to do
anything i'm saying if i were a democrat
yes trying to save my boss's job that's
what i would urge him to do but he
but veraldo makes a really good point
when you hear
people asking bill de blasio so are you
thinking about the governor it's like
it's like
it there actually is something worse out
there than cuomo
there's something worse out there and
it's like do you mean we might get more
de blasio yes
he could actually i mean he's yes
there's something worse out there and
he's right about james i mean she's as
hard left as you get so due process
here we go again all right president
biden trying to clean up confusion hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else